car culture and festival culture are
both inherently social thought to
horizon to is inherently social so we
ensure that everyone's game feels
connected even when you're not playing
multiplayer there are lots of ways to
see what your friends are doing even in
solo play your friends are always
connected to your world your friends
Drive Attar's explore the open world
with you
even when they aren't online you can
challenge them to street races or follow
them to hidden secrets in the world
rivals challenges and speed cameras
allow you to compete with your friends
asynchronously and at any point you can
pull up the map and see where your
friends are online and what they're
doing when you decide to jump into
online play we ensure that transition is
instant and seamless and by removing
lobbies the waiting and all the hoops
you have to jump through players who
don't usually play online will find it
really easy entertaining and friendly
community is massively important to Fort
Sur and with clubs have up to a thousand
players you could create your own
community within horizon - what that
Club is for though is entirely up to you
it could be a private club for you and
your close friends you could use it to
compete on the game's global Club
leaderboards we've given you the tools
to create or find the perfect club for
you we've got car meets which is a great
place to go and socialize chart and show
off your libraries or your tunes if
you're a really talented painter you can
enter a car meet and show off your
latest design anyone else that's in
there can take a look and at the touch
of a button download your design for
their own car King and infected were two
really popular online game modes from
the original horizon in Forza horizon 2
we decided to build the perfect arenas
from the ground up each one of these
arenas is designed with jumps and
smashable
items everywhere taking full advantage
of the open world
we have two main ways to play online an
online roadtrip will take you on a tour
of the world from destination to
destination and then everyone in the
session will vote on where the roadtrip
goes next in online free roam it's
entirely up to you what you do you and
the people in your session can do
whatever you like
start races play co-op challenges hunt
for secrets and collectibles together or
just cruise around there are no rules
the world and everything in it are yours
to explore together this is an
incredibly social game in every sense
we've reimagined what a truly next-gen
online experience should be you can play
it however you want do whatever you want
we'd like horizon 2 to be a game that
you play with friends but maybe even a
game in which you can make new friends